is a live look at the 15 north by the
speedway this area always backs up when
the electric daisy carnival is underway
you can see it's really backed up now
tonight there's actually another problem
for those heading out there earlier it
was really tough going take a look at
this a big mess on part of the 15
northbound right near the beltway and we
thank you so much for joining us tonight
at five o'clock i'm sasha loftis that
cleanup has been underway for hours now
madison kimbrough joins us live where
that overturn happened on the i-15 right
near the speedway and madison how's it
looking out there now
yeah sasha so take a look as you can see
crews are just finishing up hard at work
cleaning up and bulldozing the mess left
behind from the overturn that happened
around noon today this area has been
blocked off for hours now and still no
word on what caused the overturn but
luckily no one was hurt nhp tweeted out
that the cleanup process would last
about two hours but we have seen that
it's taken much longer i-15 headed north
is the way most would go to get to the
las vegas speedway and with edc going on
people are trying to find alternate
routes so there is a significant backup
due to the lane closures drivers were
directed to take lamb and also we're
seeing cars on the northern 215
interchange if you take a look you can
see that these are the cars moving
southbound and they're having no problem
moving at a rapid pace of course we will
let you know coming up at six if the
northbound lane opens up and i got to
tell you it does not smell great out
here it smells like trash so that's
great that they were able to pick all of
that up sending it back to you sasha